Special Afferents
of the Head and
Neck. Video 3.
Cranial Nerve 8.
Vestibulocochlear.
Hearing and Balance.
The vestibulocochlear
nerve comes off the
pond's medulla junction
and follows the
facial nerve out of
the endocranium via
the internal acoustic
meatus. The nerve
starts as a single
structure leaving the
brain, but it quickly
splits into two
nerves as it reaches
its destination within
the inner ear. These
two nerves are the
vestibular nerve and
the cochlear nerve.
The vestibular nerve
handles the vestibular
system, the area
associated with balance,
whereas the cochlear
nerve covers the
cochlea, which is
the organ of hearing.
Although both vestibulocochlear
and facial enter
the internal acoustic
meatus, only the
facial nerve exits
the skull. The
vestibulocochlear nerve
only goes as far as the
inner ear. The nerve
splits into finer nerves
that receive sensory
information from a
specialized organ
called the otic capsule.
The otic capsule
consists of a bony or
endosseous labyrinth.
This is a set of cavities
filled with a fluid
called perilymph.
Perilymph has a
consistency similar to
most extracellular
fluids. Just deep to
the perilymph covered
endosteous labyrinth
is a secondary
structure called the
membranous labyrinth.
This is where the
hearing and balance
organs really function.
The membranous
labyrinth is filled
with endolymph, a
positively charged
substance similar to
intracellular fluid.
The membranous
labyrinth can be divided
into the vestibular
organ and the cochlea.
The vestibular organ
provides our sense
of balance and direction.
It is comprised
of two different
structures, the
otolith organs and the
semicircular canals.
There are two
otolith organs,
the utricle and the
saccule. They are
responsible for
detecting change in
direction. They do
this via two expansions
of the bony labyrinth
that house many
small calcifications
called otoliths.
Otolith, literally
translated,
means ear rock.
These little
calcifications give
weight to the gelatin
inside the saccule
and utricle.
Embedded within
that jelly are
the cilia of
sensory neurons.
The utricle is aligned
horizontally in
the head with the
sensory neurons placed
along the floor of
the utricle in an area
called the macula.
This lets the utricle
act as a horizontal
acceleration sensor,
letting us know
where our head is in
space. Data from the
utricle is compared to
semicircular canal
data to further
determine where our head
is oriented. We will
cover the semicircular
canals in a bit.
The saccule has a
similar construction
as the utricle,
but it is placed on
the medial wall
of the vestibular
organ. The saccule
detects vertical
motion and acts as
our gravity sensor.
Lastly, we have the
semicircular canals.
These provide
information on head
tilt and position
in space. We have
three semicircular
canals, the anterior,
posterior, and lateral
semicircular canal.
The anatomy of all three
canals is the same.
Each canal is filled
with endolymph, and
each canal ends in an
expanded section called
the ampulla. Inside
the ampulla resides
the ampullary crests,
or crista ampullari.
These crests protrude
into the membranous
labyrinth and house
multiple stereocilia
attached to sensory
neurons. Each semicircular
canal works as a pair
with a semicircular
canal from the other
side of the head.
This allows us to
accurately determine our
head rotation and
orientation in space.
The three opposing
pairs of semicircular
canals are the left
and right horizontal,
the right anterior
and left posterior,
and the left anterior and
right posterior
semicircular canals.
As the head rotates
in space, these three
semicircular
canals switch their
endolymphatic fluid
around, pushing on the
ampullary crests and
bending them one way
or the other. This
bending causes
depolarization of afferent
neurons on the side
that the head is
turning towards, while
hyperpolarizing,
or inhibiting, the
aferrit neurons on the
contralateral side.
This asymmetric
firing of neurons
allows the brain
to determine
which way the
head is turning.
These movements can
seem confusing at first.
The key part to
remember is that your
brain is just measuring
the difference in
signal intensity
between the paired
semicircular canals in your
head. So, for instance,
if you turn your
head to the left,
then your left
horizontal semicircular
canal would increase
signal intensity, whereas
your right horizontal
semicircular
canal would decrease
its signal intensity.
The second portion of the
otic capsule
is the cochlea.
Cochlea means
spiral, and it earned
its name from
the snail shell
shape that it
takes in the ear.
As part of our
hearing system,
the cochlea sends all its
information to the
cochlear nerve.
Inside the cochlea,
the membranous
labyrinth continues as
the spiral ligament,
and within the
spiral ligament is
the endolymph-filled
cochlear duct.
The walls of the spiral
ligament create a
barrier that separates
the rest of the
endosseous labyrinth
into two channels, the
perilymph-filled scala
vestibuli and scala
tympani. To understand
how sound travels
through the cochlea,
we have to start in
the middle ear. At the
tympanum, sound waves
shake the tympanic
membrane, transmitting
those sound waves
to the attached ear
ossicles, the malleus,
incus, and stapes. It
is at the footplate
of the stapes that
the sound waves reach
the cochlea. The
footplate of the stapes
taps on a special window
on the cochlea called
the oval window.
This sends a pressure
wave into the perilymph
of the endosseous
labyrinth through the
scala vestibulae. This
pressure wave distorts
the cochlear duct,
stimulating afferent
neurons placed in a
specialized region of
the duct called the
organ of corti. This
structure houses sensory
neurons with cilia
encased in jelly similar
to the otolith organs
and the ampullary crests
of the semicircular
canals. These
neurons depolarize at
different harmonic
frequencies, sending their
information back to
the brain via the
cochlear nerve. That
pressure wave is then
translated to the other
channel, the scala
tympani, where its energy
is eventually released
through the round
window of the cochlea.
This is all a very
basic rundown of
sound transduction,
which you will learn
more about in
neuroanatomy. The
frequency of sound waves
entering the middle
ear determine how
far up the spiral
cochlea that sound
wave will go. Lower
sounds travel further
up the spiral.
Due to the large size
difference between our
tympanic membrane and
the footplate of the
stapes, all sounds get
naturally amplified
on their way to the
cochlea. To keep from
destroying the cochlear
membrane with very loud
sounds, we have two
built-in safeties. Those
two little ear muscles
we talked about in
the previous lecture
series, tensor tympani
and stapedius. These
little muscles lock down
the ear ossicles and
dull incoming sounds.
Clinical correlate.
Hearing loss is,
of course, the most
common clinical case
associated with the
vestibulocochlear
nerve and the ear.
Hearing loss can be
congenital, or it can
be acquired from
being around very loud
noises for an extended
period of time.
Hearing loss can
be divided into
two types, conductive
hearing loss
and sensorineural
hearing loss.
Conductive hearing
loss affects the
middle ear and is a
problem with either
the tympanum or
the ear ossicles.
A perforated tympanic
membrane or scarring
around the ear
ossicles caused by an
untreated case of
otitis media can result
in dulled sounds
reaching the cochlea.
People with conductive
hearing loss typically
speak quieter than
normal as they hear
their own voice louder
than anything around
them. This type of
hearing loss can be
treated surgically or
with a hearing aid.
Sensory neural hearing
loss is another matter
entirely. It is a
problem with the inner
ear and can include
the loss of the sensory
hair cells in the
cochlea, or it can
incorporate the cochlear
nerve itself and any
of its relays along
the way to the brain.
Treatments require
cochlear implants. However,
even these implants
produce only crude
improvements compared
to natural hearing.
Tinnitus is by far the
most common hearing
problem, affecting
some 15-20% of the
U.S. population. It
is associated with
aging as hair cells
from higher frequency
regions of the cochlea
start disappearing.
The result is a
ringing sensation
in the ear whenever the
brain checks on
that frequency.
Tinnitus is not
actually a disease, but
instead is a symptom
of a larger problem.
Tinnitus can be acquired
earlier in life by
people living or working
in very loud areas.
The ringing is
constant and typically
does not require an
outside stimulus.
The rates of tinnitus
and sensorineural
hearing loss have
been on the rise
as an entire
generation has grown up
listening to music
through earbuds.
There has been
roughly a 30% increase
in hearing loss among
young adults over
the past 20 years.
The underlying problem
is that most
earbuds don't form a
tight seal around
the external auditory
meatus, resulting
in sound leaking out
into the world and
making sounds coming
from those earbuds
appear too quiet.
The response to this
is often to raise
the volume to a listenable
level, resulting
in high decibel
sound waves hitting
the ear for extended
periods of time.
The vestibular system
is not immune to
pathologies either. A
common pathology for the
vestibular system
is benign paroxysmal
position vertigo. This
pathology is caused when
otoliths break free
from the utricle. These
otoliths find their
way into one of the
semicircular canals,
where they push against
the ampullary crests,
producing conflicting
signals about head
position to the brain.
There are multiple
causes behind
BPPV, ranging from
head trauma to age
-related tissue
weakening to the most
common reason that
it just happens.
Patients with BPPV
experience intense
and debilitating
dizziness and nausea.
The effect can
last for minutes to
days and, in really
bad cases, months.
Most cases of BPPV
resolve themselves over
time as the free
-floating otoliths are
broken down and
reabsorbed by the body.
There are treatment
options that
can speed up this
process, such as
canolith
repositioning, which is
otherwise known as
the Epley maneuver.
This technique helps
to move the rogue
otoliths out of the
offending semicircular
canal and back into
the vestibule, where
they won't cause
vertigo and will get
reabsorbed faster. In
extreme cases, surgery
may be required
to free an otolith
that has gotten hung
up on a nerve bundle.
As with olfaction
and gustation,
the eyes and
vestibular system are
another instance
of a coupled
sense, the vestibulo
-ocular reflex.
This reflex is
necessary for
proper gaze
stabilization.
We are moving our
heads and bodies around
constantly. If our
eyes did not compensate
for the rotation
of our heads, the
world would look like
a bad found footage
movie. The vestibulo
-ocular reflex
uses information relayed
from the vestibular
system through the
vestibular nerve.
Balance information
passes through several
different nuclei
in the brain before
reaching the motor
nerves for the eyes.
These motor nerves
activate the appropriate
extraocular muscles
for each eye,
allowing our eyes to
compensate for the
jittery movements of
our heads and bodies,
and keeping our view
of the world stable.
You can test this
for yourself by
holding an object
in front of your
face and rotating
your head around
while focusing
on that object.
However, to really see
the vestibulo-ocular
reflex in motion, we
need to turn to birds.
Bird eyes are so large
relative to their
skull that the
extraocular muscles are
not able to do much
to adjust the eyes.
Birds compensate
for their lack
of eye movement
by turning their
entire heads to
see something.
To maintain gaze
stabilization, the vestibulo
-ocular reflex of birds
incorporates their
neck muscles, allowing
their extremely flexible
necks to act the same
way our extra-ocular
muscles act, leading
to this wonderful
example from a 2013
Mercedes-Benz commercial.
Clinical Coralip A
delay in the vestibulo
-ocular reflex
produces nystagmus,
or an unwanted
saccade of the eyes as
they attempt to
adjust to delayed
information from the
vestibular system.
Nystagmus can be
acquired through
alcohol and
heavy drug use.
Nystagmus is a
common symptom
looked for by
police when testing
to see if someone
is intoxicated.
Nystagmus can also be
acquired congenitally.
The majority of
nystagmus cases are
benign and do not
require medical
intervention. In
rare instances of
persistent debilitating
nystagmus, a
pharmacological
treatment can be offered.
This brings us
to the end of the
lecture and the
end of video 3.